[Música]
viendo la 1:07 de la tarde en Bogotá
quito y Lima continuamos con nuestro
cubrimiento especial con motivo del
primer aniversario de la guerra en
Ucrania bien en este espacio Vamos a
repasar el aspecto mediático de la
guerra en Ucrania porque también ha sido
una batalla informativa y para ello
saludo en el estudio a nuestra compañera
Rosa Pérez Mateos Rosa bienvenida Buenos
días Andrés Valentina janetta bueno Rosa
las redes sociales han sido un un campo
de desinformación y de propaganda en
medio de esta guerra pero pues este
aspecto mediático claramente ha sido una
batalla informativa exactamente y Les
propongo empezar por recordando momento
que seguro que va a venir enseguida a
sus mentes protagonizado por la
periodista Marina oceanykova a
principios de la guerra
porque hemos querido empezar con este
momento bien porque señala no simboliza
dos cosas que queremos abordar Por un
lado la importancia de las redes
sociales porque este momento se viralizó
y pasó de la televisión rusa que fue
donde tuvo lugar esta protesta a ser
comentado en todo el mundo y por otro
lado porque también señala la censura no
que es contra lo que protestaba la
periodista que por cierto este mes de
febrero Ya vimos reaparecer en la sede
de reporteros Sin fronteras en París a
donde pretende refugiarse bien Pues esta
periodista protagonizaba entre otras
cosas contra la ley que recordemos Rusia
aprobó a principios de la guerra que
persigue hasta con cárcel las ofensas a
contra el ejército Ruso y entre estas
ofensas estaría la cuestión de llamar
guerra a lo que el kre califica
operación militar especial bien esta ley
provocó entre otras cosas que medios
independientes rusos como es el caso de
novaya gayeta quizás el más
paradigmático cesaran directamente las
operaciones pero esta censura No se
reduce solamente al territorio ruso
recordemos que tiene una dimensión
global y vamos a ver con un mapa a
continuación como los distintos bloques
podríamos decirlo así censuraron el
relato del enemigo desde el inicio de la
guerra no el 27 de febrero de 2022 la
Unión Europea vetó a sputnik y a RT el 4
de marzo Rusia empezó a vetar medios
occidentales internacionales como las
tienen la Dodge 24 o redes de sociales
sobre todo las de meta o también por
ejemplo Twitter y el 8 de mayo Estados
Unidos
prohibió también Beto las operaciones en
su país de televisiones rusas alineadas
con el kremlin bien y esto Por qué es
importante porque esta censura
digamos que las redes sociales tienen un
papel fundamental a la hora de cómo
accedemos a la información con censura o
sin en un contexto en que se está
restringida la información las redes
sociales todavía cobran más protagonista
protagonismo Disculpen y esto ha sido
fundamental a la hora de explicar la
brecha generacional que hay en Rusia en
términos de acceso a la información
sobre esta guerra esto nos lo comentaba
el periodista del Times James en un
especial que dedicamos a la guerra
informativa en Ucrania no que nos decía
que cuando empezó la guerra y el kremlin
empezó a vetar medios de comunicación
una de las búsquedas más reproducidas en
Rusia en internet era los vpns para
saltarse la censura impuesta por el
kremlin no por eso provoca que los
jóvenes tengan acceso a información que
no está filtrada por las autoridades
rusas también
este vacío informativo que han dejado
los medios tradicionales rusos ha dado
pie en Rusia de los llamados blogueros
proguerra rusos no que sobre todo a
través de Telegram han informado de lo
que sucede en la línea de frente y ellos
son tienen una línea generalmente
patriótica defienden la invasión pero
sin embargo también critican los errores
o las pérdidas que ha sufrido el
ejército ruso en el frente no y es una
comunicación que no está tan controlada
por el kremlin Y por último en la
televisión Estatal a la que acceden más
bien las personas de mediana edad o de
edad avanzada es donde se reproduce un
discurso más alineado con el discurso
oficial ruso entre otras cosas no un
discurso que asimila el gobierno de kiev
con un régimen nazi y para terminar no
con este primer repaso veamos una de las
protagonistas de estas tertulias en las
televisiones rusas que es Margarita
simonían la editora jefe de RT lo que
comentaba a raíz del control de la
información
ninguna gran nación puede existir Sin
Control sobre la información
bien Rosa y hay que recordar también que
veíamos por ejemplo como influencers y
también youtubers se convertían como una
especie de reporteros de guerra
informando desde el día uno de los
bombardeos hasta Cómo se estaban
refugiando en estos túneles y en las
estaciones del metro bien Rosa las redes
sociales también han sido un campo de
desinformación y propaganda exactamente
como lo dices Andrés hemos podido ver
por primera vez quizás a través de
tiktok no como la vida el día a día de
los refugiados ucranianos a través de
Telegram lo que comentábamos no los
blogueros en el frente de la guerra pero
Twitter también Instagram ha sido
escenario de una gran campaña de
propaganda a través de memes hemos
seleccionado El ejemplo de la santa
javelina que es esta virgen no con una
jadelina precisamente este sistema
antitanque es de fabricación
estadounidense con el que cuenta el
ejército ucraniano y es un icono que
simboliza muy bien no está este carácter
ahora mismo bélico ucraniano en el que
se junta el enaltecimiento del
nacionalismo con también la importancia
de la occidental en términos de esta
ayuda tanto económica como bélica no y
es pues desde un meme no que empezó en
redes sociales pero que acabó
convirtiéndose en un mural pintado en la
capital ucraniana en kiev por otro lado
un punto clave del discurso bélico en
las redes sociales han sido las
acusaciones cruzadas de nazismo no los
medios rusos al contrario de los medios
occidentales han dado mucha importancia
en enfatizado mucho el origen neonazi
del Batallón asov un Batallón que fue
clave en la resistencia ucraniana en
mariopol no prácticamente hace un año de
hecho hay un episodio señalado que
también comentaba mar en su Crónica de
salud que fue cuando Rusia bombardeó una
hospital maternal en esa ciudad
portuaria en ese momento solamente la
agencia estadounidense asociada Express
era el único medio internacional que
estaba presente en la zona y publicó
unas imágenes que vamos a ver a
continuación que dieron la vuelta al
mundo no y escandalizaron por los ata
que sufrieron civiles particularmente
fue protagonista de estas fotografías
una mujer embarazada y Rusia Cómo
respondió a ese episodio No ya esa
digamos visión que tuvo todo el mundo a
las atrocidades de la guerra Pues bien
dijo que eran un montaje acusaron a esta
mujer de utilizar sus conocimientos en
tanto que influencer de belleza no para
fingir las heridas también dijo Rusia
que en este hospital maternal era un
centro de operaciones del Batallón no y
sin hacer referencia explícita a este
episodio pero digamos con un informe que
se podía relacionar bastante con lo que
sucedió en maripol amnistía
internacional publicó en agosto un
reporte titulado las tácticas de combate
de Ucrania ponen en peligro a sus
civiles al situar bases militares en
áreas residenciales un informe que
generó tanta polémica en Ucrania y en
occidente que llevaron a que amnistía
personal se retractara o más bien
aclarar a su comentario y dijera que
nada justifica la agresión rusa no pero
es un ejemplo también de cómo se ha
blindado tanto el discurso a favor de
Ucrania no y en oposición a la agresión
Rusia rusa que cualquier crítica sea
tomada de forma un poco digamos
mal intencionada no Rosa algo que
tenemos que analizar y que podemos
analizar bastante bien Podría decirlo
los comunicadores es la forma de
comunicar que dista muchísimo de los dos
presidentes de estos dos países que son
bolodirse lensky por un lado y Vladimir
Putin por el otro Así es Valentina y es
una diferencia tan clara que se expresa
Incluso en los atuendos no vemos a
Vladimir Putin normalmente impoluto con
un traje y siempre digamos utiliza unos
escenarios muy podríamos decir solemnes
no Palacios estas grandes mesas unas
grandes distancias como la el salón la
mesa Lo separó de Manuel macron una
imagen que también se convirtió
enseguida en un meme que se viralizó en
las redes o incluso cuando se junta con
el pueblo en la plaza roja lugares así
lo hace desde una posición de mucha
distancia no dirigiéndose como líder
digamos
incuestionable mientras que vuelo de
lens que ha adoptado una posición
diametralmente distinta siempre con esta
camiseta militar
publicando vídeos en las redes sociales
de forma prácticamente diaria
manteniéndose en ese búnker como un
líder que no abandona su pueblo no que
está al frente de la reacción digamos de
la resistencia ucraniana y de hecho no
abandonó Ucrania durante muchísimos
meses eran los líderes aliados los que
iban a visitarle a kiev de hecho hasta
kiev fue la propia revista vogue no
donde recordemos que la primera dama
obleas de lensca protagonizó junto a
selensky un reportaje en esa revista que
causó mucha polémica y por otro lado no
en comentábamos es el que no salió
durante mucho tiempo pero sí que ya el
20 de diciembre protagonizó su primer
viaje fuera de Ucrania desde que empezó
la guerra y se desplazó en ese caso a
Estados Unidos porque es que esta guerra
No se podría entender sin el apoyo de
Washington Y de forma más general de la
otan no aquí es el curso de la guerra
habría sido sin duda radicalmente de
distinto y bien en este sentido es
también importante destacar el rol que
han tenido los medios de comunicación a
la hora de legitimar este apoyo
occidental a Ucrania No si bien Es
verdad que es una cuestión de alianzas
no y de oposición a Rusia y es una
cuestión geopolítica el propio papel de
lensky como actor al frente de su país
ha sido también clave no a la hora de
poner a Ucrania en el punto central de
la agenda internacional y esto digamos
lo resumió muy bien el editor jefe de la
revista Time cuando eligieron a
bolodimers que como persona del año en
2022 dijo su ofensiva informa tiva
cambió el clima del sistema geopolítico
desencadenando una oleada de acción que
sacudió al mundo bien antes de continuar
Yo quiero analizar este tema con nuestra
invitada Anita todos estos elementos que
Rosa menciona hacen de boladimir Celeste
en su territorio como un símbolo de
determinación de pureza Pero cómo se
percibe la imagen de Vladimir Putin en
territorio ruso
redimir Putin en el territorio ruso
sigue siendo el líder fuerte que
exactamente quiere el pueblo ruso hoy y
siempre ha querido en su historia atrás
por eso están los zares emperadores los
jefes del Estado comunistas hasta Putin
en este momento Si no es fuerte y líder
ahí está ahí la crítica con gourmet que
supuestamente se cayó Unión soviética
porque no era este líder fuerte No hay
manera como representar la nación y la
nación se identifica no solo con el
líder con un tipo de ideología que hoy
en día es vamos a decir más conservadora
porque un mundo liberal occidental es
criticado y supone con una idea de un
mundo más conservador donde hay ideales
que vienen de una familia conserva donde
no hay posibilidades de verse variedades
y una iglesia ortodoxista como un Pilar
para este tipo de política Así que
muchas veces cuando escucho Paulina en
ruso y analizo sus discursos él responde
a lo que le gusta al pueblo ruso vamos a
decir en su mayoría porque es muy
peligroso concluir generalizando que
todos son así siempre hay gente que
piensa de otra manera y se siente
profundamente en este momento indignado
por la guerra pero Putin lo hace muy
bien para los rusos están orgullosos por
lo que él hace en este momento le
responden sinceramente que están
dispuestos de ir hasta el final porque
defender la causa de esta operación
militar especial Rosa también la entre
las narrativas de ambos bloques no solo
es la forma sino que hay un enorme
discrepancia en el fondo Exactamente no
lo que comentábamos no es solo una
cuestión de cómo se presentan ante sus
respectivas poblaciones ni ante el mundo
sino también una cuestión de narrativas
ya para cerrar este espacio dos
narrativas completamente opuestas que
quedaron muy claras en la asamblea
general de Naciones Unidas el pasado mes
de septiembre cuando tanto el
representante ruso sergei labrov
ministro de exteriores de Rusia como el
presidente
ucranianonski apelaron al mismo artículo
51 de la carta de Naciones Unidas la que
recoge el derecho a la legítima defensa
para defender su acción bélica en el
conflicto actual escuchemos y con eso yo
ya termino
y hemos visto Quién es el único que
quiere la guerra
la falta de decisión de los países
occidentales y la guerra continua del
régimen de kiev contra su propio pueblo
no nos dejó más que lanzar una operación
militar especial para proteger a los
rusos y eliminar las amenazas a nuestra
seguridad que la otan ha creado
sistemáticamente en territorio ucraniano
Ucrania ha mostrado fortaleza en el
campo de batalla utilizando su derecho a
la legítima defensa de acuerdo con el
artículo 51 de la carta de la ONU
la operación se lleva a cabo en
cumplimiento de los tratados de amistad
cooperación y asistencia mutua entre
Rusia y estas repúblicas sobre la base
del artículo 51 de la carta de Naciones
Unidas
bueno además de darle las gracias a
nuestra cronista Rosa Pérez que acaba de
salir del estudio le damos las gracias
También a usted a neta por habernos
acompañado en esta casi hora y media de
especial en este primer año de la guerra
en Ucrania nosotros queremos agradecerle
toda su intervención y todo el análisis
que compartió aquí en el programa
gracias a ustedes me parece muy
importante lo que han hecho y para un
público hispanohablante que necesita
acercarse a lo que pase en el mundo
bueno Y nosotros vamos ahora a harky
porque nuestra enviada especial Irene
sabio habló con la primera viceministra
de Ucrania y ministra de reintegración
de territorios temporalmente ocupados
Irina berechuc con quien conversó sobre
cómo la guerra ha afectado Ucrania al
pueblo ucraniano Aquí les traemos un
extracto pero podrán Ver la entrevista
completa a lo largo del día en nuestra
programación
Vice primera ministra
Ucrania firmó recientemente un decreto
en el que
declaró la imposibilidad de negociar
computing cuán lejos está la posibilidad
de la reactivación de un diálogo y
cuáles son las condiciones de Ucrania
para que este diálogo se reinicie
para gobierno con
buccaína Y
en este momento nuestras mejores
negociadores y diplomáticos son los
soldados están eliminando al enemigo así
negocian Esta es la única alternativa
que tenemos hoy el kremlin y Rusia no
nos han dejado otra opción han visto y
oído lo que su líder un criminal como
Putin dice y hace está preparándose para
una gran guerra es lo que ha dicho por
eso necesitamos las armas y las
necesitamos rápido eso le quitará la
posibilidad a Rusia de atacarnos y de
atacar a otros países y llevar adelante
una agresiva guerra en el mundo
y bien de Ucrania nos vamos hasta el
territorio ruso para conectar con Javier
colaz nuestro corresponsal en mosc
abierre Buenas tardes se cumple un año
de lo que el presidente Putin calificó
como una operación militar especial cuál
es el ánimo del pueblo ruso ha crecido o
ha disminuido el apoyo ciudadano
Bueno pues el gobierno trata de instalar
en la gente una moral de Victoria pero
lo que detectamos aquí muchas veces es
como mucho moral ya secas nada más en el
régimen de Vladimir Putin esperaba hace
un año que se iba a tratar de una
invasión corta fugaz una operación
Relámpago que desbancase a lensky del
Poder y se ha encontrado con una guerra
larga y cruenta con ya demasiados
ataúdes volviendo a casa y Rusia desde
el principio Vladimir Putin ha tratado
de no despertar a la opinión pública
rusa convenciéndoles de que no se
trataba
pero ahora que ha avanzado tantísimo el
tiempo y han pasado 12 meses Putin está
cambiando el foco y ya no hace tanto
hincapié en que se trata de una
operación militar especial para
desmitificar a un país que se estaba
convirtiendo en una amenaza para la
seguridad de Rusia sino que pone el foco
en la gran gesta que supone para está
enfrentándose a occidente sobre todo a
Estados Unidos y a la otan en general no
a sus soldados pero sí a sus armas y a
su información de inteligencia en el
campo de batalla que supone Ucrania más
que un país es concebido como un campo
de batalla para ese pulso con occidente
por eso
vladin Putin igual que los rusos sabe
que se encuentra entre un año difícil
donde se van a empezar a notar las
sanciones y quiere asegurarse de que
todos los rusos están en el mismo barco
es decir sabiendo que se encuentran en
una segunda edición de la Guerra Fría
más cruenta y que aunque las los efectos
y las incomodidades de esa guerra se
noten en casa el objetivo es recuperar
la hegemonía mundial O al menos
disputarse en Estados Unidos y hacerle
perder eso que los rusos llaman el
monopolio de las relaciones
internacionales que tiene ahora
hablamos constantemente de sanciones y
hablamos de cómo occidente Está tratando
de aislar de alguna manera a Rusia pero
este impacto realmente se ha sentido en
territorio ruso
poco a poco se va notando Pero la verdad
es que las sanciones occidentales en un
primer momento han tenido un efecto
mucho menor de lo que venían pregonando
los políticos europeos por ejemplo con
Estados Unidos respecto a un posible
derrumbe de la economía rusa se ha
notado mucho por ejemplo en los precios
los precios de los productos en los
productos básicos y hay que recordar que
en el caso de Rusia en la cesta de la
compra en muchos casos hay muchos
productos que vienen del extranjero
Entonces ha habido productos que en el
primer momento faltaron que después han
sido sustituidos por otros llegados a
otros lugares pero que en general los
precios desde luego han subido Y eso lo
han notado bastante los rusos el segundo
componente Aunque este ya no acepta
gente son las dificultades para entrar y
salir del país un asunto que al
principio era simplemente una desventaja
desde el punto de vista del ocio del
tiempo libre Porque además se ha
convertido en un problema que atosiga
muchos recursos que en realidad no están
preocupados por las vacaciones sino que
están preocupados y mucho Sobre si van a
poder huir a tiempo si existe un segundo
reclutamiento una segunda movilización
como la que vimos en los meses de
septiembre y octubre los expertos
coinciden en que las sanciones harán se
notarán todavía más su efecto Durante
este año 2023 y por eso es por lo que el
kreming está insuflando tantísimo
contenido patriótico incluso no solo los
medios de comunicación sino las propias
escuelas rusas donde se pide a los niños
que escriban cartas a los soldados
porque va a hacer falta mucho
Patriotismo para olvidar los dolores del
frigorífico de la mesa del armario donde
se guarda la comida de los precios lo
que ocurre en el mercado hacer la compra
En definitiva la vida cotidiana que se
hace más difícil Gracias Javier colás
nuestro corresponsal de France 24 vemos
q Muchas gracias por este reporte y
también vamos a hablar del impacto
económico que ha tenido esta guerra en
Ucrania de la bienvenida en el estudio a
mi compañero Jorge Hurtado Jorge hablaba
nuestro corresponsal saber cuál es hace
un momento del impacto que han tenido
las sanciones pero en este aniversario
occidente anunció más sanciones
cuéntenos Así es Y bueno no solo van a
tocar el crimen sino también aquellos
que apoyen a Rusia en Europa Asia y
medio oriente concretamente Habrá más
aranceles sobre los productos rusos
importados a Estados Unidos que incluyen
más de 100 metales minerales y productos
químicos por un valor aproximado de
2.800 millones de dólares anuales el
departamento de comercio también
impondrá controles de exportación a casi
90 empresas rusas y de terceros países
incluso china Washington se unió así a
sus socios del g7 que planean hacer lo
mismo en conjunto así como la Unión
Europea que prepara un décimo paquete
escuchamos y parte de lo que decía el
ministro de finanzas francés al respecto
los juegos
por supuesto deberíamos imponer
sanciones adicionales Europa Lo está
pensando y trabajando en ello
y por cierto las sanciones son
eficientes todas son fuertes y
eficientes
y estoy profundamente convencido de que
a largo plazo lo serán cada vez más
debilitando la economía rusa y dando
todos los resultados concretos que
esperamos de ellas
Jorge un año de guerra en Ucrania
claramente ha dejado varias crisis en
varios ámbitos pero centrémonos en la
crisis energética Bueno hay que recordar
que Rusia suministraba el 40% de las
necesidades energéticas de la Unión
Europea y con la invasión y las
posteriores sanciones el continente se
enfrentó al desafío de descubrir cómo
iba a reemplazar rápidamente ese gas y
petróleo rusos a nivel mundial el primer
impacto se sufrió cuando el petróleo
subió brevemente
a 139 dólares el barril hace un año
precisamente pero volvió a caer
alrededor de los 80 dólares el barril
después de que quedó claro que el efecto
de estas sanciones occidentales sobre el
volumen de las exportaciones de petróleo
de Moscú había sido de cierta forma
limitado Jorge Qué ha pasado con los
precios de la energía en Europa bueno
los precios del gas en Europa han caído
hasta un 85% desde que alcanzaron su
punto máximo el verano pasado eso ha
debido de cierta forma la presión sobre
los bolsillos de los consumidores el
precio por megavatio hora que es una
medida que se usa venía subiendo desde
antes de la invasión y oscilaba entre 50
y 100 euros por megavatio hora durante
la Guerra se llegó a disparar a más de
300 euros por eh megavatios hora en ese
verano Y desde entonces han venido
cayendo hasta los 50 euros inclusive
menos que antes de que estallara este
conflicto pero los gobiernos europeos
que han gastado casi 800 mil millones de
euros en subsidios de energía de hogares
Y también a las empresas y se preguntan
cuánto tiempo pueden mantener este tipo
de ayudas Jorge Qué implicaciones ha
tenido esta crisis energética bueno Hay
muchísimas y sobre todo la podemos
mencionar que los gobiernos en Europa
han gastado miles de millones de euros
como mencionábamos subsidiando las
facturas de la calefacción algo muy
polémico porque esto ocurre mientras las
compañías energéticas obtienen ganancias
récord y ha llevado al bloque europeo a
pensar en cómo pueden modificar las
reglas del mercado para que eso no
ocurra también otro factor importante es
que los países están compitiendo para
construir terminales y poder importar
gases de nuevos proveedores como Estados
Unidos
Qatar o Nigeria la diferencia es que es
mucho más costoso porque hay que
transportarlo como líquido en barcazas y
luego regasificarlos Bueno una de las
grandes preguntas es qué pasará el
próximo invierno
Bueno listo más importante de Europa es
que no sufrió un apagón como mucho se
temían Aunque la demanda de gas suele
dispararse a principios de octubre el
invierno estuvo más templado de lo
habitual Y eso retrasó las salidas de
los inventarios que ya venían
recolectando al cierre 2022 Europa tenía
sus tanques de reserva llenos en más del
80% ahora si no se ahorra gasolina en
este invierno también Sería mucho más
difícil llenar el almacenamiento para el
próximo lo dijo hace poco farid virol
director ejecutivo de la agencia
internacional de energía que publicamos
parte de esa declaración dijo que Europa
ha hecho esfuerzos impresionantes para
superar la crisis del gas este invierno
lo que también muestra claramente que
Rusia está perdiendo la guerra
energética según él pero como le comentó
a Úrsula Legend a todos los comisarios
de la Unión Europea no hay tiempo para
la autocomplacencia con una prueba más
dura por delante el próximo invierno
Jorge la otra crisis es alimentaria
tenemos que ser con Pues que hay
millones de personas que están en estos
momentos en una condición de hambre
extrema y muchas de ellas Pues están en
esta situación tan crítica por este
efecto dominó de la guerra Cómo se ha
medido en cifras esa crisis alimentaria
Bueno antes de la guerra Ucrania y Rusia
ostentaban una tercera parte de las
exportaciones mundiales de trigo una
quinta parte del Maíz y un 80% del
aceite de girasol también eran los
principales proveedores mundiales de
África medio oriente y partes de Asia
donde ya muchos están luchando
históricamente contra la inseguridad
alimentaria Rusia también era su
principal proveedor de fertilizantes
Jorge para aliviar la situación en julio
se llegó a un acuerdo para que Ucrania
pudiera reanudar la exportación de
granos que ha pasado con este pacto y
cómo se han comportado los precios de
los alimentos Bueno hay que recordar que
Durante los primeros meses de guerra se
dejaron unos 20 millones de toneladas de
granos atrapadas en los puertos
ucranianos y Ucrania solía exportar del
mar entre 5 y 6 millones de toneladas de
productos agrícolas al mes Turquía
Naciones Unidas gestionaron este pacto
para poder sacar esta cantidad de granos
Y de alguna forma aliviar la crisis
alimentaria Ucrania ya pidió que se
extendiera por un año más pero Rusia ha
señalado que no está contenta con
algunos puntos de este pacto y todavía
esa situación de alguna forma podría
decirse que es incierta Jorge cómo se
han comportado los precios de los
alimentos bueno los precios de los
alimentos a nivel mundial tuvieron un
repuntes bastante significativos sobre
todo en los primeros meses de la guerra
por esta misma situación que
mencionábamos anteriormente por la
cantidad de fertilizantes por ejemplo
que se producen en Ucrania y Rusia y
esto hizo que se afectaran países
latinoamericanos como Brasil por ejemplo
Colombia que importan muchos de estos
fertilizantes para producir alimentos
una situación que todavía continúa
aunque los precios Ya bajaron de esta
bajaron esta oscilación tan brusca que
tuvieron los primeros meses de la guerra
pero los precios continúan bastante alto
según el programa mundial de alimentos
bien Ahora Jorge Hurtado con la
información económica Muchas gracias Y a
esta hora ya nos acompaña en el estudio
un nuevo invitado para este análisis
aquí en France 24 con Este
descubrimiento especial del primer año
de la guerra en Ucrania él es Daniel
Meyer analista internacional y docente
del departamento de derecho
constitucional de la Universidad
externado de Colombia bienvenido
estábamos hablando hace un momento de
las sanciones son muchos temas alrededor
del impacto económico que ha tenido esta
guerra en Ucrania mencionada justamente
Jorge las sanciones y también lo hacía
nuestro corresponsal Xavier collage Cuál
es el impacto real de estas sanciones en
territorio ruso
Pues en general Yo diría que Rusia
sufrió menos que el resto del mundo de
las sanciones y es sorprendente Porque
primero en tiempos de guerra el gobierno
ruso está dispuesto de dictar a su
pueblo así son las condiciones ahora y
también crisis alimentaria energética
eso no son productos de lujo eso es algo
que vulnera inmediatamente a una
población un un país como gana en África
que está tan dependiendo de alimentos de
Ucrania no puede vivir ni cuatro semanas
en esto Entonces el impacto de las de
las sanciones y las respuestas rusas en
esto no son bastante balancear verdad es
sorprendente porque se pensaba antes que
serían mucho más fuertes y
forzarían a Rusia de cambiar su
estrategia pero hasta ahora no se ha
visto mar Cos al inicio los sancionados
fueron oligarcas y funcionarios rusa fue
expulsado del sistema bancario Swift y
solo fue hasta finales del año pasado
que empezaron a sancionar los
hidrocarburos A qué se debió esta
decisión
pues es Claro si tú estás dependiendo y
rectángulos no estás dispuesto de
muy fácilmente
abandonarlos Entonces es eso va a causar
mucho ruido también por las fricciones
entre Estados Unidos y ropa adentro
especialmente Alemania adentro de la
otan sabemos que con esta este tuvo en
el Báltico ha causado muchos problemas
que los
americanos dijeron unos días antes de la
guerra si ellos invadieron vamos a
bombardear este este tubo eso es lo que
pasó entonces
esos son son cosas que es muy difícil
porque obviamente Alemania es un Francia
también es un país industrializado y es
como alimentos para África lo mismo es
energía para países industriales ellos
no pueden decir pues vivimos un año sin
energía y vamos a ver qué pasa esto no
no por eso yo digo a buen raro o ropa
también estas medidas Marcos el año
pasado el pib ruso se contrajo 2,5%
mucho menos de los que se esperaba que
le ha permitido a Rusia mantenerse a
pesar de estas sanciones
Pues sí acomolarlo verdad nosotros no
compramos nuestros combustibles ahora
directamente en rosas sino por desviar
de India India gana mucho plata con esto
si hay demanda siempre hay oferta y sube
el precio eso es una ley económica y
también se busca otras fuentes pero
Rusia No yo no creo que Rusia va a
sucumbir a estas a estas estas
sanciones no parece bueno algo que llama
la atención Es que las sanciones contra
Rusia no son de este momento Rusia ya
venía siendo sancionado desde 2014 desde
la anexión de crimea de alguna manera se
puede pensar que el kremlin y que Moscú
con todo su en todos los ámbitos se
Estaba preparando para poder sobrevivir
a otro tipo de sanciones más adelante
pues tenemos que recordar que la
concepción de esta guerra es bastante
diferente en el occidente que en Rusia
Rusia es un imperio
victorioso de secundaria Guerra Mundial
ellos pidieron 20 millones regalos en
esto y ellos se sientan como entre las
naciones grandes del mundo y la
percepción en Europa es muy diferente la
percepción en Europa son corruptos son
pobres son post comunistas esto es uno
de los de las razones por la cual el
conflicto no llega a una lengua
compartida me entiendes Entonces tenemos
que recordar que
me pedía un poco me ayudas no estaba
preguntándole si si de alguna manera
Rusia ya estaba preparándose para para
ser sancionado para sobrevivir a pesar
de estas sanciones exactamente y por
esto Rusia no va a
va a hacer sufrir a su propia población
Y es que es más importante los usos
están dispuestos a defender esto y yo
quiero Añadir una Yo quiero ponerme unos
zapatos de los rusos un poco en un
momento el conflicto inicial es un
conflicto real y los rusos tienen buenas
cartas en esto es esto no empezó ni en
2022 ni en 2015 eso empezó hace como 15
años con el cambio del gobierno en kiev
de este más o menos recibiendo órdenes
de este Moscú como minx todavía el bebé
loros hacía un régimen más democrático
más hacia el occidente en este momento
los rusos tenían miedo de perder control
no solamente del Báltico de Polonia de
Romina tenemos que recordar que Rusia ha
sido un imperio gigante y cayó
normalmente los imperios que caían
generan una energía enorme Austria
imperio ausmánico tenían con crímenes de
guerras horribles Entonces hasta ahora
tenemos que dar mucho respeto a que los
rusos dejaron salir Báltico Polonia
Rumanía todo esto y yo creo llegaron a
un punto con Ucrania con la membresía de
Ucrania en la Nata donde dijeron No eso
es algo que no vamos a aceptar hemos
dicho Ok váyanse pero eso es algo que no
solamente consistiano gente que son
rusos para nosotros los ucranios son
rusos en un sentido lingüístico
histórico kiev era capital de Rusia
antes de Moscú o San Petersburgo pero sí
Y eso era la primera etapa en esta
tierra re incorporar Ucrania
miraron que los ucranios no querían pero
ahora Estamos hablando de un conflicto
muy localizado es los rusos 20% de los
rusos que se sientan como los rusos
victoriosos de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
que no quieren vivir en una Ucrania que
se vuelve más y más occidental
eso es algo que pasó en yugoslavia y se
hizo nuevas fronteras en yugoslavia
también parte de la Cueva de los últimos
sismos de la guerra fría y yo creo
podemos ver este conflicto como parte de
este caída de la unión
sismos de la de la Guerra Fría el
peligro que veo en esto En este
conflicto bien localizado con un
problema específico que se puede
negociar el estado de los rusos adentro
de Ucrania son 20% y ellos quieren
pertenecer a Rusia
lo que tenemos que evitar a cualquier
costo Y eso es la ruptura en mi análisis
entre Estados Unidos y Europa en este
conflicto ropa es más en esto
apaguémoslo no dejémoslo escalar más
Estados Unidos está más pensando en
geopolítica yo escuché lo que en la
conferencia inmune Hace unos días y el
tema ya era el rol de ropa en la
geopolítica nueva y el La pregunta es
qué rol jugará o ropa frente a Estados
Unidos y china en el futuro por eso era
tan importante tan deseado
frente a este conflicto donde no se
aliaron con los rusos pero dijeron
Nosotros somos totalmente neutrales no
queremos que se desarrolle este
conflicto específico localizable en una
pregunta global sobre Pacífico sobre el
rol de la otan y todo esto pero yo veo
mucho peligro si no tratamos con mucho
cuidado este conflicto y localizamos y
limitamos que esto sea exactamente la
pregunta
Marcos ahorita lo mencionamos hace un
momento Estados Unidos y sus Aliados del
g7 anunciaron una nueva avalancha de
sanciones contra Rusia usted me
corregirá ningún otro país había sido
sancionado de esta manera como está
siendo sancionado Rusia Qué otros
sectores o qué otras sanciones se pueden
esperar y a qué sectores no han llegado
estas acciones
Pues todo el sistema bancario No
no ha tocado en su totalidad
pero yo creo la lógica de este conflicto
no es más en la diplomacia y no en en la
economía la lógica ahora es militar y la
lógica militar es o ganas o pierdes
entonces no es algo que dices pues vamos
un poco más adelante miremos Cómo
funcionan no tú mueres otro tú matas
entonces me entienden yo yo creo Tenemos
que tener claro cada día mueran cientos
de rusos y ucranios en esto y eso ya
genera una amargura que va mucho más
allá de las negociaciones y diplomacias
es algo muy sorprendente también para
nosotros de hecho al inicio nosotros
pensamos poco pero han vivido juntos y
ambos rusos qué está pasando allá pero
obviamente no es así la fricción entre
los rusos y los
hacia 90 años con el Domo y todo eso
todas estas historias crean una
determinación en ambos lados que
sorprendente verdad porque como he dicho
el conflicto en sí mismos algo
localizable y mínimable negociable yo
diría claro Bueno pues Andrés Marcus
estábamos hablando un poco de A qué
sectores ha llegado o han llegado estas
sanciones y por ejemplo podemos decir
que incluso el deporte se ha visto
afectado por varias formas en primer
lugar Pues por un veto que se le dio a
los a los deportistas rusos por algunas
federaciones deportivas entonces doy la
bienvenida a nuestro compañero Luis
Méndez que nos va a hablar de toda esta
información deportiva bienvenido Luis
cómo ha impactado la guerra al deporte
ruso bien hablaban de esa sanción Y por
supuesto que este sector no escapado a
ellas hay que mencionar en primer lugar
lo que ha sido por parte de la FIFA y la
UEFA de las competencias oficiales tanto
de los clubes como de la selección de
Rusia en los diferentes organismos
también hay que señalar la lo que fue el
veto la suspensión de algunos eventos en
el territorio ruso pero vamos a
especificar lo que fue el caso de
wimbledon estamos hablando de el
circuito ATP de tenis y que impidió la
participación tanto de atletas de Rusia
y de belarus en el Torneo que se realizó
en 2022 una medida que en su momento no
fue compartida por la ATP o la
asociación de tenistas profesionales y
por ello decidió no entregar puntos al
ganador aún así Daniel Posteriormente se
vería perjudicado ya que tenía el
liderato del ranking de este organismo y
unas semanas después por su condición de
número uno del mundo y no haber podido
participar en algunos eventos que Se
realizaron en territorio británico per
esta condición pero también está el caso
de Nikita mazepin un expiloto de Fórmula
uno que salió de la escuderías vale
decir que esta es de origen
estadounidense Y aunque en su momento la
culminación del contrato se dio por la
prohibición de la Fiat de que los
pilotos portasen escudos o insignias de
Rusia esta escudería contaba también con
un patrocinante Ruso pero muy en el
fondo de manera extraoficial este equipo
tuvo temor Porque algunos países
europeos los cuales en su mayoría cogen
grandes premios le pudiesen cerrar la
puerta a masepín para participar en esas
competencias Pero quizás el caso que
mayor impacto generó en el deporte ruso
fue el tema de la economía de los clubes
y de las elecciones por ejemplo en el
caso del fútbol el spartak de Moscú
aseguró 8 millones de euros por alcanzar
los octavos de final de la Europa League
pero dejó
haber llegado a la final unos seis
millones de dólares más esto por no
haber podido clasificarse también está
el caso de la selección la selección de
Rusia por no clasificará Qatar
recordemos que fue suspendida para
participar en el repechaje europeo dejó
de ganar entre 8 y 9 millones de dólares
y además por perder la sede de la final
de la Champions que se iba a efectuar en
San Petersburgo el año pasado aunque no
hay datos oficiales podemos tener una
idea comparándola con la final del año
2019 que se celebró en Madrid en aquel
entonces Y tuvo un impacto económico de
137 millones 600 mil dólares esta cifra
están fuera de lo que es el impacto a
nivel turístico y a ello debemos sumar
la pérdida por la suspensión del Grand
Prix de Fórmula 1 y también la pérdida
de ingresos por no haber podido recibir
la Copa Mundial de voleibol masculino
bien Luis ahí detallaba cada uno de los
deportes que se han visto afectados el
veto que se ha impuesto por varias
federaciones atletas rusos y bielorrusos
Pero cuéntenos cómo han reaccionado
estos deportistas hay posiciones
encontradas a Andrés uno sobre todos
aquellos que están más expuestos a
viajes por su carrera como es el caso
específico de los de los tenistas han
preferido mantener una posición más
neutral otros han respaldado la posición
de Rusia sobre Ucrania e incluso han
mostrado símbolos característicos de esa
operación especial militar Pero hay otro
grupo y vale decir que este es muy
pequeño que en Rusia se ha pronunciado
en contra de la guerra y de hecho ha
pedido que busquen maneras para
encontrar la paz es el caso específico
de Igor dennishop quien es un futbolista
profesional y le pidió al presidente
Vladimir Putin parar la guerra en una
cita que hacía los medios de Rusia
manifestó estoy dispuesto a arrodillarme
ante usted así lo dijo este futbolista
pero como ya mencionamos a nivel
profesional estas sanciones tienen
implicaciones económicas y también
consecuencias en lo deportivo algunos
atletas tienen mucho tiempo preparándose
para competencias internacionales y
recordemos que el caso de la Copa del
Mundo fue el más emblemático pero
también está el de los Juegos Olímpicos
de París donde Ucrania a través de su
presidente ha pedido la no participación
de atletas de Rusia y de pelarus y
amenazado incluso con un boicot Pues
todo ese esfuerzo de los futbolistas y
en el caso también de los Olímpicos de
los atletas podría generarles problemas
en lo deportivo pero más allá de todo
esto también algunos deportistas pero de
otras nacionalidades se han visto
afectados por la situación hay que
señalar que de acuerdo con el diario el
País de España el base francés toma
huttel había sido expulsado de la
selección de su país que ya está
clasificada la Copa del Mundo de
baloncesto de este año por haber fichado
con el Cenit de San Petersburgo una
situación similar habría ocurrido con el
sueco Jonas Pro quien fue el primer NBA
de ese país y que también ha sido
excluido por su firma con el chesca de
Moscú Luis Tenemos que hablar también
como la guerra ha impactado al deporte
ucraniano Así es que hablar que lo ha
impactado de diversas maneras también en
lo económico Pero principalmente ha
causado estragos en la infraestructura
deportiva de acuerdo con datos del
Ministerio del deporte ruso más de
trescientas instalaciones deportivas han
sido destruidas y ha obligado a los
atletas de Ucrania a solicitar acceso a
otras naciones para poder llevar a cabo
los entrenamientos también ha causado un
impacto en cuanto al daño económico en
los clubes y las elecciones pero lo más
triste está en el impacto del conflicto
en el deporte y la mente de sus familias
ya que muchos deportistas entrenadores y
figuras relacionadas con el deporte han
muerto bien sea en combate o hechos
relacionados con la guerra
lo que fue el inicio de esta operación
militar en marzo se dieron a conocer los
primeros datos de deportistas que
murieron en combate de acuerdo con el
sindicato internacional de futbolistas
dos jugadores de menos de 26 años había
muerto por estar combatiendo en ese
conflicto también la federación de
deportes de invierno dio a conocer la
muerte de
un joven de 19 años quien practica o
practicaba el vía Trump pero esta cifra
se incrementó a 77 en el mes de agosto
justo cuando se estaban conmemorando
seis meses de esta incursión militar y
hay que manifestar que para febrero del
año 2023 el ministro de deportes
ucraniano refirió a la agencia reuters
que alrededor de 220 personas entre
deportistas y también aquellos que
tienen labores relacionadas con el
deporte habrían muerto como consecuencia
de la guerra pero desde el principio
muchos atletas o deportistas se unieron
en las unidades de de Ucrania quizás los
casos más sonados fueron los de los
boxeadores o Alexander ucik actualmente
el campeón del peso completo y el telex
campeón Brasil y lomachenko Quienes se
unieron a los batallones de batalla para
defender a Ucrania pero también hay que
destacar que un practicante de las artes
marciales mixtas
después de ganar el título de peso
Walter de pelator en junio de 2021 puso
a su familia salvo y se trasladó a
Ucrania para defender a sus países
escuchemos el relato
y y ha estado bastante
de eso no tenía entrenamiento militar y
trataba de no tocar Las Armas creo que
como para toda persona cuando Se
involucra por primera vez en actividades
militares primero tiene que
acostumbrarse esperamos
Luis mencionaba usted que los jugadores
que pertenecen a los clubes ucranianos
se encontraban inactivos en el momento
de el repechaje para Qatar Qué pasó con
esa liga hay que señalar que esta liga
tenía alrededor de ocho meses sin
actividad primero porque hacen una pausa
en el invierno debido a las condiciones
climáticas pero posteriormente debió
concluir por lo que es la guerra en este
particular a nivel de Clubes ya se
reanudó en en agosto del pasado año a
pesar de una prohibición de la FIFA para
que los jugadores extranjeros que están
formando parte de los clubes ucranianos
pudiesen salir de estos equipos y
trasladarse a otras ligas vale de
mencionar que el shakhtar Doña es t
Ucrania logró avanzar a los octavos de
final de la Europa League al vencer al
René Francés pero hay otros casos
emblemáticos que se han dado dentro del
deporte porque allí entonces vimos
cuando precisamente el propio día de la
incursión militar en Ucrania el equipo
Nacional ucraniano de baloncesto tuvo
que disputar un partido en España como
parte del proceso eliminatorio Ya
retomando en cuanto a la liga de fútbol
a esta se está jugando con 16 clubes
estarán disputando unas 30 fechas pero
bajo condiciones de seguridad extremas
entre ellas la colocación de un búnker
alrededor de 500 metros de cada uno de
los estadios donde se disputan los
partidos en caso de ser atacados Luis
una pregunta en la liga solamente
participan jugadores ucranianos no en
estos momentos hay un 13% de jugadores
que forman parte o que son extranjeros
que están formando parte de esta liga
pero es una cifra muy mínima si la
comparamos con ejemplo la Liga de España
donde actualmente hay alrededor de un
47,2% de jugadores que proceden de otras
latitudes de ese Universo de 414
jugadores alrededor de 54 son de el
extranjero 25 de ellos proceden de
América Latina y el Caribe son de Brasil
Luis Muchas gracias por este análisis y
por esta radiografía todo de este
impacto que ha tenido la guerra en
Ucrania sobre el deporte y bien vamos a
volver al análisis con nuestro invitado
Marcus Daniel Meyer hablamos ya del
impacto económico que ha tenido la
guerra en Ucrania hablamos de el papel
de la otan que son aliados de Ucrania y
que ha sido fundamentales para que
Ucrania pueda resistir en el campo de
batalla pero hablemos también ahora de
los aliados de Rusia Quiénes son Y cómo
han contribuido en esta guerra
pues eso es una muy buena pregunta
porque nosotros pensamos que la otan es
como el mundo libre y importante y estos
rusos no no
[Música]
cumplen hay otros poderes muy
importantes en esto Brasil India y China
Entonces ellos
por ejemplo Brasil ha hecho nosotros no
vamos a vender a munición a Alemania
para esta guerra no vamos a vender
armas para una un conflicto que no nos
toca India está muy poderosa es el país
con más gente en el mundo está neutral y
especialmente el roi de China preparando
como algo en el Pacífico y este
conflicto que ya vemos eso es muy
importante china ha tratado este asunto
con mucho cuidado Yo leí su comunicado
Porque muchos listas pensaron que China
y Rusia por su ideología compartida y
por ser grandes poderes se unieron mucho
más en contra del occidente en esto Esto
no ha pasado
incluso estos tres Brasil India y China
han propuesto una conferencia de Paz
donde ellos como terceros neutrales
podrían negociar eso es un eso siempre
es algo que te da mucho poder en alemán
porque obviamente tú puedes balancear
los poderes
hasta ahora no veo muy concreto este
propuesta pero como he dicho este
conflicto se podría extender en repartir
las cartas a nivel geopolítico y ojalá
que no pero en este contexto podría ser
que digamos el los neutrales desde la
Guerra Fría de hecho
ganen ganen más poder y más influencia
eso es posible Bueno usted ya estaba
mencionando el papel que tiene China
como Aliado de Rusia y Es que ayer pues
Naciones Unidas la asamblea general
realizó esta votación que tuvo 141
apoyos no solo para pedir el retiro
inmediato de las tropas rusas de
territorio ucraniano sino también una
paz justa y duradera china se abstuvo
presentó un plan de paz de 12 puntos
algo que según Úrsula Van Der Legend la
presidenta la comisión europea no es
concreto ella dijo que son principios
otros líderes aseguraron que el papel
mediador de china No es creíble porque
no ha habido una condena de Beijing al
actuar de Moscú y que la propuesta debe
mejorarse para ser creíble Cómo se puede
analizar el papel de china
pues empecemos con lo positivo unos
pensaron que China
aprovecharía la posibilidad de ocupar
Taiwán en este momento donde el
occidente la otan ya está como muy
la situación en una situación muy tensa
ocurrió Y entonces
veo como he dicho china muy cuidadoso
con su nuevo rol no quiere provocar pero
es obvio que no
seas Aliado del occidente de la de la
otan en este contexto que no era por
esperar tampoco entonces
verdad yo veo muy constructivo el rollo
chino en esto en un sentido de no poder
su peso en la báscula que podemos decir
por ejemplo el papel de los países de
América Latina Tienen alguna relevancia
pues hasta ahora no hablan con una voz
entonces
Brasil está Clara y es un peso Pesado en
el campo internacional ya ha dicho que
no quieren Añadir más combustible esto
conflicto obviamente países como Cuba
como Venezuela como Nicaragua están
claramente en favor de Rusia Pero eso no
no son
macizos Yo quiero Añadir un poco si me
permiten un pensamiento porque yo tomo
un poco la el rol del abogado del [__]
aquí
recordemos que hace 60 años
teníamos una situación comparable con
Estados Unidos
o Rusia dice nuestra seguridad esta
amenazada si la otan se extienda hacia
Como mil kilómetros de Moscú nosotros
hicimos nosotros la nota o tal no es así
pero recordamos cuando Rusia deploró a
más nucleares en Cuba hace 60 años la
reacción no era pues es un país libre
viva con esto las emociones las Naciones
Unidas no los Estados Unidos dijeron No
nosotros arriesgamos una guerra nuclear
si ustedes no retiran Estas armas
nucleares y los cubanos Y los rusos sí
lo hicieron Para mí es algo
yo les pregunto algo si china habría un
contrato de cooperación económica y
militar con México mañana
yo creo Estados Unidos no deberían pues
cada país es libre de forma sus alianzas
Entonces tenemos que tener un poco yo
creo tenemos que alejarnos un poco de
esta
formalismo jurídico de ellos gentes
etcétera tenemos que ver estamos
hablando de historia y de poderes para
apagar este conflicto y no ser ingenuo
tampoco bueno algo que cabe Resaltar
aquí es justamente
como el armamento nuclear está teniendo
un papel clave y es cómo se pueden
atacar por ejemplo como lo que ocurrió
en la planta de saporilla todo lo que
está ocurriendo en la planta por ella y
también el riesgo que hubo en chernóbil
Cómo podemos nosotros analizar esta
situación cuando este tipo de armamento
prácticamente podría acabar con todo
eso es muy importante hay que hay que
separar dos cosas es el uso civil de la
de la energía nuclear y la el armamento
nuclear aunque los efectos son lo mismo
son devastadoras absolutamente en la
Guerra Fría de hecho lo paradójico que
era porque son tan letales estas
armamentos que era casi considerar
imposible hacer una guerra nuclear y el
mundo estaba bajo amenaza de esto pero
muy Pacífico en el sentido ahora Estamos
en una nueva situación Y es pues si
alguien amenaza con amas nucleares cada
día como Putin lo hacen aumento es algo
que se que se usa que algo que se cómo
se dice es baja la La amenaza con el
tiempo entonces no me gusta que que
están empujando en este lado
frecuentemente porque obviamente como he
dicho si esto se desarrolló en una un
conflicto geopolítico a nivel global
estamos hablando de cosas muy horribles
entonces
Cómo podemos evitar ambos
yo creo hay que hay que hay que ser
realista con los poderes con el poder
militar de los rusos hay que mirar que
ya estamos en un año y llegar a una
conclusión que refleja el poder Ruso y
que también refleja la necesidad de los
cráneos de separarse definitivamente de
la Unión soviética o de Rusia porque eso
eso es el asunto yo creo hace desde hace
varios meses
mosco ha venido haciendo referencia a su
Arsenal nuclear y de hecho esta semana
el presidente Vladimir Putin se retiró
del tratado de New Start se trata de una
campaña de intimidación o en verdad
puede llegar a usar su Arsenal nuclear
pues la lógica militar es siempre 50%
acción 50% psicología yo género miedo en
ti que no hagas algo entonces y las los
analistas estaban sorprendidos que
amenazó desde el inicio de utilizar
amamento nuclear Eso fue concebido como
algo exagerado y un símbolo para su
debilidad pero como he dicho repetirlo
varias veces significa pues no lo vas a
hacer de todos modos y entonces eso
puede provocar reacciones
muy peligrosos entonces
Rusia es una potencia con la cual
tenemos que vivir también después de
esta guerra termine como termina y será
un poder nuclear y será un país inmenso
es el país más grande del mundo de hecho
todavía aún que han pedido mucho
territorio con los y es mejor pensar ya
en la paz y en la estructura después de
este conflicto que
escalarlo No sí O sea que escalar más yo
creo Entonces eso es importante yo creo
Usted está hablando del futuro y tenemos
que hablar del futuro a partir de mañana
Ucrania va a entrar en su segundo año de
guerra hacia donde se dirige este
conflicto
Dónde está la bola de vidrio
y yo Yo tengo dos visiones hay que leer
guerras hay que leer conflictos que es
detrás y abstrae también de mucho mucha
propaganda recordamos misma que dijo
nunca hay tantas mentiras que antes la
elección durante la Guerra y después de
un matrimonio
entonces hay mucha propaganda en todos
lados entonces hay dos maneras de leer
esto conflicto es un conflicto sobre el
rol de la minoridad Rosa rusa en Ucrania
West del río Ginebra eso es algo que sí
se puede resolver con voluntad en ambos
lados no van a ganar 100% pero si puede
negociar esto sería importante Tener
suficiente presión militar por parte de
la otan para decir Rusia retírense de
cualquier cosa restablecer el
Imperio soviético zarista etcétera eso
no va a pasar ya Unidos y determinados
entonces hablamos de Luján stonex esos
son partes pequeños del mundo
eso sería lo lo bien y eso sí se puede
relacionar la segunda opción es mucho
más grave la segunda opción sería
Estados Unidos insista en humillar y
danza es como se dice hacer pequeño a
Rusia para prevenir más influencia en el
Pacífico y una alianza potente entre
China y Rusia Esto es algo que tenemos
que evitar a cualquier costo yo creo
estaba hablando hace unos minutos el
presidente y decía que él descartaba
completamente el conflicto mientras eh
el ejército ruso estuviera realizando
ataques en territorio ruso teniendo en
cuenta esto y bueno teniendo en cuenta
este
esta disponibilidad o esta falta de
disponibilidad para el diálogo porque
tampoco la tiene Rusia Cuáles son otros
escenarios posibles para un eventual fin
de la guerra
pues la pregunta en este es Sí verdad
queremos solamente limitarnos al
conflicto sobre el rol de los rusos en
Ucrania este del la pregunta en mins 1 y
2 Entre y Merkel y Putin era cual va
primero primero plebiscito sobre su
estado autónomo y nuevo o nuevas
fronteras o primero retirar la parte
militar y no pueden acotar los ucranios
dijeron No mientras los rusos están en
territorio ucraño no vamos a negociar
los rusos dijeron tenemos que defender
nuestro pueblo en Ucrania porque tenían
unas leyes que verdad eran muy
cuestionable contra los rusos acá
entonces pero yo creo eso sí se puede
resolucionar yo creo
tendríamos que encontrar un estatus muy
autónomo para los rusos en en
yugoslavia disolver parte
desconectar parte de Ucrania y dalo a
Rusia porque eso es lo que quiere la
gente que viva ya
Bueno pues justamente estamos hablando
del futuro estamos hablando de el estado
en el que se encuentra en este momento
Ucrania y no solo Tenemos que hablar de
los ataques que se han producido claro
con con su debida proporción contra las
personas contra los centros
hospitalarios contra la red la
infraestructura pero algo de lo que
también tenemos que hablar es del
patrimonio del patrimonio ucraniano si
lo vemos de alguna manera
encaminándolo más hacia la cultura este
patrimonio cultural que claramente se ha
visto afectado por la guerra y sobre
todo pues por estos bombardeos que
dañaron sitios históricos e incluso a
veces destruyeron para siempre obras de
arte por eso vamos a hablar de este tema
con nuestra cronista ella es él
bienvenida lea bienvenida bienvenida a
este estudio y a este especial qué
podemos decir sobre este patrimonio
ucraniano un año después del comienzo de
la ofensiva rusa bueno la distribución
del patrimonio histórico en por las
bombas rusas es algo que tenían los
profesionales de la cultura y los
conservadores pero también el mismo
gobierno ucraniano por lo que Vladimir
Putin expresó expresó varias veces que
quería controlar el territorio pero
también la narrativa histórica entonces
para debilitar un pueblo y una nación
hay que borrar su patrimonio su historia
y su cultura Aquí vemos justamente una
cita de la directora de cultura y
urgencias de la unescola Organización de
Naciones Unidas para la cultura las
ciencias y la educación cristal que
plantea bien el riesgo al atacar
el patrimonio ella advirtió a finales de
octubre sobre la invasión rusa que el
patrimonio cultural suele ser una
víctima colateral de Las Guerras pero a
veces es atacado precisamente porque es
la esencia de la identidad de un país y
lo hemos visto durante todo este año en
las imágenes que circularon del
conflicto este patrimonio atacado son
Iglesias teatros museos bibliotecas y
otros monumentos hay un caso que
conmocionó particularmente al comienzo
de la guerra en febrero el museo de
ivanquiva al norte de
incendió durante un ataque del ejército
ruso todos pensaron en el momento que
con él se quemaron las obras de María
primash una de las grandes artistas
autodidactas del siglo 20 pero unos
valientes residentes lograron salvar de
las llamas la gran mayoría de esas
pinturas que los bombardeos no son la
única amenaza para el patrimonio
ucraniano no exactamente Andrés además
de las bombas el frío puede hacer
También mucho daño a las obras y con los
contantes
cortes de electricidad en ciertas
regiones de Ucrania la conservación del
del arte se se dificulta también hay
mucho vandalismo con el ejemplo de este
museo de gerson en el sur de Ucrania al
retomar la ciudad de los rusos los
empleados
acá descubrieron un saqueo como con las
ventanas destrozadas y estanterías
vacías entonces para evitar todo esto
algunos museos intentaron sacar sus
obras del país como fue el caso de unas
70 pinturas que salieron de ucraneal 15
de noviembre ahí fueron llevadas al
museo dicen borde misa de Madrid en
España la mayoría de esos cuadros nunca
habían salido del territorio y están
reunidos en la exposición en el ojo de
la tormenta vanguardias de Ucrania se
pueden ver allá hasta abril y luego Irán
al museo de Colonia en Alemania fue una
operación delicada cuya preparación
lleva semanas para una exposición muy
simbólica como lo cuentan la
conservadora del museo español y la
coculadora de la exposición
la exposición surge como con esa doble
vertiente por un lado
enseñar un arte que se les conoce en
España y en todo occidente y por otro
sacar obras
del territorio en guerra y evitar que
sean destruidas por los bombardeos
de
los cuadros salieron fue el día en que
se produjo el bombardeo más intenso en
Ucrania y por suerte las furgonetas con
las obras de arte Salieron un par de
horas antes de que comenzaran los
bombardeos ya se estaban desplazando por
el país pero aún así fue extremadamente
estresante para todos los implicados y
estuvimos constantemente en contacto con
los conductores para asegurarnos de que
estaban bien y fueron increíbles
lea dentro del patrimonio la mayoría de
las obras no se pueden desplazar estoy
hablando Por ejemplo pues de los
edificios no cómo se afrontó este
problema Bueno Valentina desde hace un
año los trabajadores naturales y la
población también hacen todo lo posible
para proteger los monumentos de la
guerra a bloquear ventanas cubrir las
vidrieras con pantallas protectoras
envolver estatuas y cubrirlas de sacos
de arena como lo hemos visto visto sobre
sobre todo en Odessa Lamentablemente
esos esfuerzos no fueron rivales para
las bombas rusas y por eso
organizaciones como la UNESCO se
muestran muy preocupadas según los
registros de la agencia de la ONU hasta
el 22 de febrero hace dos días la
invasión rusa dañó al menos 241 sitios
del patrimonio cultural del país y es
por esa inquietud que la UNESCO tuvo la
decisión a finales de enero de inscribir
el centro histórico de Odessa como
patrimonio mundial en peligro lo que
reconoce su valor universal excepcional
era un deseo que el presidente ucraniano
había expresado rápidamente cuando
empezó la invención rusa y las imágenes
que están viendo Ahora son de marzo del
año pasado de un reportaje que nos grabó
nuestra corresponsal en el terreno
Catalina Gómez Ángel un año después
podemos ver que la ciudad parece un poco
menos en guerra pero el reto de
preservación de su patrimonio no cambió
con este nuevo estatus jurídico las los
estados miembros de la ONU se
comprometen a hacer todo lo posible para
proteger este sitio por lo que tienen
una obligación legal con la comunidad
internacional escuchamos las reacciones
de la directora general de la UNESCO y
del ministro ucraniano de cultura
primero hay la dimensión simbólica de
decir que esta ciudad pertenece al
patrimonio mundial nos concierne a todos
todos tenemos los ojos puestos en ella y
reconocemos su historia y su
contribución al patrimonio
luego hay una dimensión jurídica de
protección porque hay una convención
internacional de protección del
patrimonio mundial firmada por 194
estados miembros Y contiene la
obligación de los estados miembros de no
destruir deliberadamente el patrimonio
lo que supondría un incumplimiento de
sus propias obligaciones internacionales
están matando a nuestros ciudadanos
están dañando nuestro patrimonio
cultural lugares hogares Y quieren
seguir haciéndolo espero de verdad que
el paraguas de la UNESCO el escudo azul
pueda proteger al menos los cielos de
Odessa y a la propia odesa de estos
bárbaros ataques de los rusos durante
esta guerra
bueno ley para finalizar nos puede
hablar de cómo estos diferentes actores
que están luchando para proteger el
patrimonio cultural de Ucrania están
trabajando desde ya sí es que pensar en
el fin de esta guerra también hace parte
de las prioridades frente al robo de
obras pero también a los traslados a
otros países como lo hemos visto la las
organizaciones están ayudando a preparar
inventarios una medida prevista en la
convención allá sobre la protección de
los bienes culturales en tiempos de
guerra originalmente escritos a mano
estos inventarios están destinados a ser
digitalizados y junto a los inventarios
la UNESCO también está trabajando con
imágenes por satélite para vigilar la
destrucción de bienes culturales y
patrimoniales
nuestra principal responsabilidad es
asegurarnos de que disponemos de
información sobre la situación de los
yacimientos para estar preparados para
la reconstrucción Pero sabemos que en
circunstancias anteriores esta
documentación también ha sido utilizada
por las autoridades del país si quieren
investigar acusaciones de crímenes de
guerra
y para concluir sobre el tema de la
digitalización del patrimonio ucraniano
y de internet como un lugar que se
volvió necesario en esta guerra quería
hablar de
una aplicación móvil de escaneo que
convierte a cualquier ucraniano en
archivista digital capturando edificios
monumentos y otros elementos como
modelos 3D con su teléfono y los guarda
automáticamente en una base de datos es
una documentación digital que busca
transmitir la herencia cultural del país
a las generaciones futuras y que incluso
podría algún día ayudar a la
reconstrucción de lo destruido Lee usted
muchas gracias por todo este análisis
cultural que realmente sí va a ser muy
difícil pero Esperamos que se pueda
lograr Y es que volvemos con nuestro
invitado con Marcus Mayer porque le
quiero preguntar justamente por este
tema de la reconstrucción porque podemos
hablar de tiempo y dinero para
reconstruir cosas físicas pero es
posible reconstruir moralmente
pues yo creo las heridas entre Ucrania y
rusos son muy muy profundos Y ya
y
son cosas lo mismo en yugoslavia tú
tenías un cuervo que viví juntos 40 años
y después tienes de un día a otro esta
amargura este odio
yo creo lo más importante es encontrar
una solución política para para la paz
que sirva para los rusos y los ucranios
hay que recordar que la diferencia no es
tan grande el 50% de los huraños hablan
ruso que es algo raro y dices que
Entonces qué es la diferencia ni étnico
ni religioso ni nada entonces todo lo
que faltó para un conflicto digamos
tradicional entre dos religiones dos
etnias entre pobres y ricos etcétera
esto faltó totalmente en caso de
conflicto de Ucrania Entonces
yo creo
será Será muy difícil reconciliar estos
dos
estos dos pues ni son dos pueblos estos
dos partes de la comunidad rusa después
del conflicto y lo más temprano lo
apagamos lo mejor obviamente
ahora cuál va a ser este costo social de
una generación que viene de dos años de
restricciones por la pandemia del Coby
19 y ahora un año de una guerra que no
se sabe todavía para dónde va O sea que
recordar que unen tres es un poco cínico
de los europeos en este es los
refugiados han salido muchos refugiados
de Ucrania que saben leer y escribir
estudiados etcétera etcétera y ya viven
dos un año en Alemania en Francia
etcétera La pregunta es ellos van a
regresar o van a ver si vivo muy bien
aquí los alemanes ofrecen muchos
beneficios para ellos mucho trabajo
etcétera entonces para digamos
la Ucrania postguera será un país muy
muy diferente de la Ucrania posoviética
eso ya es claro también Los costos y la
Unión Europea va a incorporarla la
Ucrania en un tratado con Rusia o no eso
ya se negoció no bueno y
perdón y que no quieren volver cómo se
repara la pérdida de un país la pérdida
de sus vidas
Pues a nivel mundial ya tenemos una gran
casa para los mejores Mentes entonces
gente estudiado Son
son lo que generan en economías modernas
ingresos impuestos entonces y son libres
Entonces si ellos deciden quedarse en
Francia en Alemania en Italia sea lo que
sea es imposible no son prisioneros de
guerra como antes mencionan no puedes
decir mira ustedes van ustedes
pertenecen al Estado
todas estas cosas no se han tocado
todavía pero eso también juega un papel
inmenso en este conflicto obviamente no
Marcos Gracias por acompañarnos aquí a
analizar los diferentes aspectos de toda
esta devastación que ha dejado la guerra
Cómo ha afectado también a en diferentes
ámbitos a los ciudadanos ucranianos a
los rusos y también al resto del mundo
bien De esta manera llegamos al final de
este espacio Agradeciendo a nuestras
enviadas especiales Catalina Gómez Ángel
Irene sabio y Emmanuel chas y a nuestro
corresponsal en Moscú Javier colas y
también a nuestros invitados en plato
vaneta del mar y conómova que nos
acompañó en la primera hora y Marcus
Mayer a ustedes también por acompañarnos
en este espacio especial cuando se
cumplieron 365 días de la guerra en
Ucrania Buena tarde para todos nosotros
los dejamos con este recuento de
imágenes que dejaron huella en este año
de la invasión rusa a territorio
ucraniano
[Música]